if you're looking for your next big
business opportunity alibaba's Jack Ma
has the answer roll the clip and I don't
want to tell young people so most people
complain where's the opportunities
people start complaining
some people complain some stuff people
start change themselves changing others
where the opportunities is where the
complaints are where the travel where is
the opportunity and I was really there I
like to believe that entrepreneurs we're
not big complainers we're problem
solvers when we see something that's
having a huge impact on our life in a
negative way we strive to go out and
change it and make the world a better
place so I can definitely relate to this
message from Jack Ma in my first
business I had a biotech software
company and my two business partners
were both in the biotech field as
researchers and they were upset at how
difficult the software was to use the
other competitor software had tons of
features that was really difficult to
use and a lot of scientists their
colleagues and themselves they were
complaining about how difficult it was
so instead of just sitting back and
complaining and saying this is this
sucks these companies are terrible we
set out to make something easier and the
software that we created wasn't the most
advanced software in the world it didn't
have all of the functions that our
competitors had but it was the easiest
software to use and was the most
visually appealing so we took a problem
that a lot of people had a knee in the
street and that my co-founders had as
well and we turned it into a solution
the same thing happened with my website
I'm a chemical calm I had found that
famous entrepreneur stories were key
learning mechanism for me the story of
how Bill Gates launched Microsoft
literally saved my company and kept me
from having to go get a job and it was
frustrated that there wasn't a great
resource to share all of these stories
of famous entrepreneurs their lessons
and how they got started there wasn't
any great books there wasn't any great
web resources so I went out to start
creating it myself and when I became
known for Devin Carmichael calm was
building the largest collection of
famous entrepreneur profiles and stories
anywhere online and that turned into not
only a money-making opportunity for me
but something that was of genuine
interest and value to the entrepreneur
community so you need to do the same
thing for your business if you're
thinking about what business to start or
if you're looking for how do I take the
idea that I have and turn into something
more powerful look at the biggest pain
point look at where you are personally
complaining and feeling like man I'm so
frustrated with how this thing is
working right now and turn that
frustration into an opportunity to help
your business grow and of course belief
thank you guys so much for watching I
love to hear what you have to think
about Jack Moz advice if you want to
leave it in the comments below I'd also
love to hear what problems you solved
with your business or what problem
you're aiming to solve and what
frustration that came out of and I'm
going to be joining in discussion so I
really want to hear from you down there
if you liked this video and you want to
see more don't forget to subscribe to
the channel until the newsletter thank
you so much for watching have a
fantastic day and I'll see you soon